- It's just so funny thinking
about how vacation seems like a
million years ago literally
was just thinking like how not
motivated I am for the showman
aspect of this, you know?
Not only am I back in the grind,
I'm like so deeply
in it that like...
It was funny somebody left a
comment, I ended the episode
two episodes ago I guess
with like just a grimy.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- And the guy, you
see his comment?
He was like, "What do you mean
grimy and hustle and execution?
"All this guys does is walk
"around and shake
people's hands."
(upbeat music)
Have a good day.
Let me just, I'll back up where
I can the punchline is that, you
know, if you weren't the first
mover on the platform itself,
you can still be a first mover
by being the first
mover in a new feature.
Like live video capabilities or
in this example filters or some
other or Instagram stories.
There's always gonna be
new feature builds on these
platforms that allow a new
opportunity to be the first
mover tactically
instead within that platform.
So, kind of think of it like
real estate where you might've
not been first in California but
you can be first in Malibu and
so it's like neighborhood, you
know, buying up neighborhoods
instead of buying
up New York City.
The person, here's a great
example there's a lot of people
that made money in Manhattan and
New York but you could've been
the person that
made money in Dumbo.
So the bottom line is this
is continuing to happen.
Every person reading this
article still can deploy this
exact strategy which is why I'm
featuring it to all of you if
you are targeting
13 to 35-year-olds.
Yep.
I make decisions that are
predicated on whether this
person is telling the truth or
not, is relevant on making this
decision because of x.
I think when you
actually have less
expectation of others,
there's an
incredible life to be lived.
It's stunning how
little I expect from others.
I take it as a pleasant surprise
and as a positive when one does
the normal base thing
that a human should do.
I think that most people start
with way too high expectations
and then people disappoint them.
I go the reverse and thus it
makes it easy for me so
I've never been really
ever crippled by the
notion of is this person
telling me the truth.
You want the real information,
to me I'm a postgame guy.
If they're not telling the
truth I'll deal with that later.
I'm not worried
about it that moment.
Dwelling, overthinking slows you
down and that becomes a problem.
That to me is the KPI, speed.
I think it's actually
pretty easy to judge a speaker.
For example, I think I have
substance but I have a lot of
motivational
tendencies above it.
I also think it's important
to see what they've done.
For example, you know, if
they're actually, if she or he
is actually building
businesses and they happen to be
motivational then you know that
there's something happening in
their day job, right?
If they're just coming
out the gate and saying,
"I'm a motivational guru,"
and only sell books and
only do seminars
then that's what they do.
I've struggled with the notion
of this
motivational thing.
I've got motivational
tendencies but
I've been so proud of actually
building two very
large tangible businesses.
Being an actual investor.
Making stuff happen.
So I think you just have to
dissect the words and more
importantly words are only a
very small part of the equation.
What are the actions
outside of those words
I think really matter.
This is fancy.
- [Charlamagne] My
brother, what's up, man?
- [Gary] Sup baby?
- You good?
- [Gary] Really good.
Good to see you again.
How are you?
- [Man] I'm feeling good.
- [Gary] Sup man?
Good to see you.
How are you?
Sup man, how are you?
- [Charlamagne] Why do
you say what I'm thinking?
Yeah, it seems like people like
you are saying what
I'm going to do.
- Because I don't like
counting fucking chickens, Cha.
Honestly, I've done well.
I've made it.
I'm good.
I want to keep
winning but I don't know.
Maybe I fall off, like
I want to stay hungry.
I'm not ready to you
know DRock's like,
"Hey this cabbie
he knew who you were."
I'm like, "No, no he just saw
that you were with you know with
"a camera with me."
I have big enough ego in me
already I gotta make sure that
I have big enough humility to go
with it 'cause that's
how you get somewhere.
Second you think you've
won, somebody's gonna creep.
- [Charlamagne] Word up.
- That's so real.
I'm scared of that.
Especially for as much shit as
I talk, like I'm gonna buy the
Jets, I'm fuckin'
suffocating myself.
Put myself in corner of
never being able to let off.
So back to your question,
back to your question
everybody's got their reality.
- [Charlamagne] Right.
- Everybody's got their reality.
My answer to this is, so I'm
gonna give an answer that is
valuable to everybody listening
and I'm gonna give the real
answer which is not as valuable.
The real answer is
I don't fuckin' know.
The real answer is that
guy needs to know himself.
Some people learn, if that guy
knows himself and he knows he's
a good student and he doesn't
have ambition to buy the
New York Jets and his ambition
is to make $81,000 a year,
be on three softball teams,
have good work-life balance,
get his one or two vacations a year,
not have a whole lot of stress,
well then school and
go into the machine.
If he's like me and couldn't
breathe in school, fuckin' hated
school, needs the action,
fuckin' needs, fuckin' wants to
stick computers in his brain
'cause he needs action well then
he needs to just go and just do.
If he's looking for a lotto
ticket make a business plan.
Business plans is
the whack one on that.
Business plans is the bullshit,
that's the marriage of the two
above that means nothing.
It's half-pregnant.
Business plans are bullshit in
today's world because
you don't need them.
- [Charlamagne] Just do it.
- [Gary] That's right.
Who the fuck are you pitching?
That old white dude
doesn't matter any more.
Like what PowerPoint do
you need to get, you know?
So, you know what that's called?
That's called someone being in
a fantasy in their own mind.
And that's the person who
says to their homies,
"I've got a business plan."
- [Charlamagne] Right.
- That's just a proxy.
That's peacocking bullshit.
There is no business plan.
Go do shit.
I've fought against that my
whole life 'cause I think it's
the cheesy thing.
I don't want to be a
motivational speaker,
weird conference halls.
Like that's weird but if I
can be a businessman that has
motivational DNA, well, that's
interesting because then what
the difference is I think a lot
of motivational speakers just
keep wanting to
go to the bottom.
They almost, like I basically
want nobody to watch me.
I want people to consume
my shit, get a couple ideas,
get pumped, and go do.
- [Charlamagne]
GaryVee, ladies and gentlemen.
- Alright. Love you guys.
- [Charlamagne] Wait, you want
to tell them where to find you?
- No.
- [Charlamagne] Alright.
(laughter)
- [Man 2] Don't watch his
videos, don't follow him.
- I want them to get inspired
of something here and
go do something.
(laughter)
Love you guys, thank you.
What'd you show?
- We showed the Apple Watch app.
- [Gary] Cheers.
- We showed the Apple Watch--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Ben] New
notification center.
Which is like a major
step forward in terms of...
(inaudible) actions and
it leads to the watch.
And this is like all the
alerts you can get on the watch.
I guess we're
technically into Thursday.
Good stuff.
Good day for Resy.
Good day for a
bunch of meetings.
Just met up with Sacca, my boy.
He's a shark.
I like that.
It's good to see him.
Just good to put in
another day's work.
Good solid day's work.
The work, it trumps everything.
It's the one non-debatable.
Can debate talent,
you can debate luck.
You can debate circumstance,
you can't debate if
somebody's putting in the work.
Not subjective mother fuckers.
You either put in the
15, 16, 18 hours of work.
It gives you the best position
to succeed in what you're trying
to achieve or you don't.
So,
you can have opinions but you
can't debate the fucking data.
I think about putting in the
work in the same way
I think about having the
best product, right?
Like the best product just wins.
There's so much
that is debatable.
Things that can't put
your fingers on but
the market is
the market is the market.
The market decides the best
products and you the market
watch this and understand like
look you can come up with all
your theories all you want
putting in the fucking work.
By putting in the work.
(light music)